um I mentioned earlier in the program
that there was a really important
Milestone relating to Fox News that had
been achieved and I want to talk about
that now for the first time ever Newsmax
TV got a higher rating a larger audience
than Fox News at a particular point in
time this has never happened before and
this relates to so many stories and
issues that we're following this story
is about the Brewing Republican Civil
War this story is about the growing war
between some trumpists and even Trump
and Fox News and this story is also
about the next two years of political
media recall that Donald Trump for the
last year
but especially after the election has
started going after Fox News why because
Fox News accurately reported sometimes
that Joe Biden won the election that's
it that's what Fox News did that has
attracted the ire of the president and
many of his followers and Trump started
talking about Fox is done you got to
watch Newsmax now you've got to watch
oan and these channels Newsmax and oam
at oan are so outrageous that they
actually make Fox News look slightly
reasonable if you watch at certain times
of day and we've talked about how this
will have an effect then in fact even at
various Trump rallies when they
interview attendees and they are asked
you know even Fox News has called this
why don't you believe it they will say
Fox News is part of the left now you
have to watch oan and Newsmax so this is
trickling down to more and more people
this idea that fox is now part of the
left
um and so this had a real impact in
terms of ratings as well this is just
one data point but it's the first of its
kind kind Monday night
in What's called the demo the key
demographic of 25 to 54 year old viewers
Greg Kelly reports which is a show on
Newsmax had more viewers than the Martha
McCallum show on Fox News at the exact
same time now it was a really small
margin 229 000 to 203 000 really small
margin but it's still a first because
prior to the election the numbers were
not even close for Newsmax ever now one
thing that remains to be seen is whether
Newsmax grows online when Trump
mentioned Newsmax Newsmax got a ton of
YouTube subscribers like for example
they now have 1.7 million we only have
1.1 almost 1.2 million but in terms of
views on about half the days we get more
views on YouTube than Newsmax does so
just because people subscribe doesn't
necessarily mean they're consuming the
content but even without knowing that
this is a huge media story because I've
often explained
it's not so much that it's the number of
people watching Fox News or Newsmax or
listening to Rush that matters it's that
they set the agenda for those who watch
and that then trickles down through the
right wing of sphere and with Trump in
the White House Fox News has literally
been setting the agenda something will
appear on Fox News and within minutes
Trump tweets about it and it becomes a
story for hours or for a day or two or
or even for weeks in some cases so even
though only a few million people might
ever see one Fox News show it has agenda
setting power and that's what might
change after Trump leaves office if
Trump starts giving exclusives to oan
and Newsmax even without huge viewership
oan and Newsmax could start agenda
setting for the right and that again
would be a completely humiliating
debasement of American Media and culture
and remember Fox News really caught on
around the Bill Clinton impeachment Fox
News started in 1996 and then when the
Clinton impeachment took place from 98
to 99
Fox News exploded and became more like
what it has been recently in the exact
same way Trump's entire they stole the
election Fiasco of 2020 could be what
puts Newsmax in oan in a similar
position and sort of here to stay in
right-wing media which is really really
scary for me it's interesting because
it'll be fascinating to cover this for
the next two years but for the country
it's terrible and the more people that
are getting the new their news from
Outlets like this uh the worse off the
country is going to be